I'm watching a mole on my face, and not sure if I need to go to the dermatologist,
is there something that I could put on it to prevent it from turning into anything bad?
Um, well, when you have it on your face, that's another thing, because,
um, you know, if you had a mole on your arm, you could put black sap on it,
to make sure it's not melanoma or sarcoma. If it was, then you'd have this reaction,
it would become painful, and you'd have to follow some protocols in order for that to come out as an
scar. If it's on your face, and it is a melanoma or sarcoma, you could do the same thing, but you're
going to end up with a great big scar on your face, you better know what you're getting into beforehand.
If you think it could be a, uh, basal cell carcinoma, very carbon on your face,
you could use, uh, oregano oil or, uh, or frankincense or other essential oil,
oregano oil, I would say, as, um, you know, we've seen a lot of people with basal cell carcinobus,
but you should google pictures of different types of cancer to get an idea, uh,
basal cell carcinobus is, they all pretty much look the same, have a little shite-yness to them,
if you looked at a picture of google, you'd say, oh, that's what it looks like, or, yeah, it's not that.
If it is a black dark colored mole, then it's more likely a mole, or if it is a cancer, then your choice
is to, uh, you could still try an essential oil, and there is a way I say you could try that on your
face as typically as not going to leave a scar or anything like that. Um, you could use curcumin cream
as well, we've used a curcumin cream, um, makeup, your own curcumin cream with just a cream base
of choice, hopefully organic with some powdered turmeric mix it up together and you could dab it on
your face, but just remember, it's going to stain, could stain, give it a little yellow-skinned
stain, and it will stain your pillowcase and things like that. So just remember, curcumin is very, um,
uh, you know, stains your clothes and things, uh, those are some things to look at. If you go to a
dermatologist, you know, with a dermatologist experience and looking at cancers, he or she may say,
oh, that's just a moment, worry about it, or they may say, well, we should biopsy that, then you're
talking about, you're opening up the can of worms with that. So, uh, it's just your choice, um, if you
look at it's, you know, closely and you could kind of gauge it with some pictures on the internet,
you can get some ideas of what a can of can't be, and then you could use the most gentle approach
to be doing essential oils, or to make cream on it.